a
passer dans le tunnel. Jean-
Sébastien Cloutier est allé.
Reportage terrain sur ce
troisième lien.
- C'est ici, aux abords de
cette sortie de l'autoroute 20 à
Lévis, que commencera le tunnel
du troisième lien. Il se
terminera 8,3 km plus loin, près
du Centre Vidéotron en basse-
ville de Québec. Ce serait
le tunnel autoroutier le plus
large au monde. Six voies de
circulation sur deux étages y
seront aménagées : quatre voies
pour les voitures, deux pour
les autobus. Deux sorties
du côté de Québec relieront
le tunnel au futur tramway.
Le projet pourrait coûter
entre 7 et 10 milliards $.
- Énorme... Ça manque de
modestie.
- Je trouve ça très, très bien.
Puis il faut évoluer. Arrêtons
de... Surtout à Québec, les gens
sont jamais d'accord pour ci,
pour ça. Ils ont peur d'avoir
peur.
- Le troisième lien, c'est
affreux. C'est un gaspillage
d'argent. On pourrait mettre
l'argent dans des places
beaucoup plus intéressantes que
ça.
- Moi, je choisirais entre
le troisième lien et le tramway.
Un des deux. Je préférerais
le troisième lien.
- Oui? Pourquoi?
- Plus utile à long terme.
- Dans la région de Québec,
où les heures de pointes sont de
plus en plus difficiles, l'appui
au projet tel que présenté
oscille entre 47 et 60 %,
selon deux sondages parus
la semaine dernière.
Nous avons demandé une entrevue
avec le directeur du bureau de
projet du troisième lien,
mais elle nous a été refusée.
Le cabinet du ministre des
Transports François Bonnardel
nous a plutôt référé
au porte-parole du MTQ.
NICOLAS VIGNAULT,
porte-parole, MTQ
- Selon les évaluations
du bureau de projet là, il y a
environ entre 50 000 et 55 000
véhicules par jour qui vont
utiliser le tunnel, et ça fait
en sorte qu'il y a un potentiel
de réduire les débits de
circulation ou la congestion sur
les deux ponts d'environ 15 %.
- L'achalandage estimé est donc
presque trois fois moins élevé
que celui du nouveau pont
Samuel-de-Champlain qui, lui,
a coûté deux fois moins cher
à 4,2 milliards $.
BRUNO MASSICOTTE, prof.,
École Polytechnique Montréal
- La grande région de Québec
a besoin d'une amélioration
de la mobilité et je pense que
le troisième lien est requis.
- En 2015, l'ingénieur
Bruno Massicotte a eu le mandat
d'étudier un tracé qui passait
sous la pointe de l'île
d'Orléans, plus à l'est.
Trop en périphérie, ce projet
n'a pas été retenu et
l'ingénieur peut le comprendre.
Mais il se pose des questions
sur le projet annoncé.
- C'est difficile de voir
comment on est passé de
4 milliards, même en considérant
l'inflation, à un projet
autour de 10 milliards.
- Avec tout cet argent, pense-t-
il, on pourrait construire
un court tunnel pour le tramway
entre Québec et Lévis
en plus d'un nouveau pont
pour les voitures à côté
des deux autres, plus à l'ouest.
- Plus on fait quelque chose qui
est standard ou qui a déjà été
fait, qu'on connaît bien,
pour lequel on peut contrôler
les paramètres, bien ça fait
baisser les coûts. Plus on fait
quelque chose qui est à risque,
comme creuser un tunnel de 8 km,
bien ça comporte plus de
risques. Et plus de risques
dit des coûts plus élevés.
- Le choix d'opter pour
un tunnel d'un seul tube à deux
étages fait partie des défis,
entre autres parce qu'un
tunnelier de plus de 19 mètres
de diamètre sera nécessaire pour
creuser. Aucun d'aussi gros n'a
encore été conçu sur la planète.
À Seattle aux États-Unis,
un tunnel de deux étages a été
inauguré en 2019, mais il est
un peu plus petit. Le tunnelier
avait 17 mètres de diamètre.
- À Seattle, il y avait
un tunnelier qui était fait pour
creuser dans le sable et il a
rencontré une tige, ou des tiges
métalliques, et les couteaux
se sont brisés. Et pour changer
les couteaux, il a fallu creuser
un puits. A ce que je sache,
ça a retardé d'une année ou deux
le projet avec les coûts
non seulement du retard,
mais aussi de l'excavation.
- On parle déjà d'au moins
13 forages qui ont déjà été
effectués, tant du côté
de Québec que Lévis et même dans
le fleuve Saint-Laurent. Alors
vraiment, toutes les études
nécessaires seront réalisées
pour éviter justement qu'on ait
des surprises avec le tunnelier.
- Selon le ministère des
Transports, c'est en 2027 qu'on
commencera à creuser le tunnel.
Qu'est-ce que vous dites
aux gens qui disent :
on va fort un peu?
- Bien en fait, on parle
d'une infrastructure qui serait
en place pour une centaine
d'années. Et ça fait en sorte
qu'il faut se projeter vers
l'avenir. C'est ce qu'a fait
le bureau de projet en disant :
il y aura du développement
économique, il y aura
du développement démographique
dans la grande région de Québec.
- Et c'est surtout
sur la Rive-Sud de Québec que
le troisième lien favorisera le
développement. Ceux qui habitent
dans l'est de Chaudière-
Appalaches et qui travaillent
au centre-ville n'auront plus
à faire le grand tour.
MARIE-JOSÉE MORENCY, DG,
Chambre de commerce de Lévis
- On a de la congestion
routière, nos entreprises
veulent être aussi attractives
et retenir leur main-d'oeuvre.
Il y a énormément de pertes de
temps, je vous le cacherai pas,
sur les réseaux routiers. Elles
veulent être compétitives aussi.
Il faut arrêter de penser que
des projets économiques
avec des retombées économiques,
c'est contre l'environnement.
- Face à l'île d'Orléans,
Beaumont est une jolie
municipalité tranquille
où résident 3000 personnes.
L'entrée du tunnel sera située
à 10 km de là.
Le maire est content.
DAVID CHRISTOPHER,
maire de Beaumont
- Ça va aider pour la région
de la MRC de Bellechasse,
la MRC de Montmagny.
C'est notre développement
économique. On est en train de
refaire notre plan d'urbanisme
pour 2036. 2036. Ça fait qu'on a
de la place dans le moment
pour 350-400 maisons
à construire dans le moment.
- Il précise que les terres
agricoles ne devront pas être
touchées. Mais l'UPA s'inquiète
pour les producteurs
de la région.
JEAN LAMBERT,
UPA Chaudière-Appalaches
- Une fois le projet terminé,
ça va être possiblement
de l'étalement urbain et des
municipalités qui vont vouloir
agrandir leur périmètre urbain.
Puis ça se fait tout le temps au
détriment de la zone agricole.
On n'a jamais été consultés pour
dire : là, il y a beaucoup de
terres agricoles, vous devriez
peut-être regarder une autre
option. Ça a pas été fait.
Le bureau de projet a absolument
pas fait ça et le gouvernement
non plus.
- La prémisse est que c'est
nécessaire. Or, cette prémisse-
là, elle est même pas fondée,
elle est même pas prouvée!
- Pour Jean Dubé, professeur
en développement régional
à l'Université Laval, le projet
est tout simplement mauvais.
JEAN DUBÉ, prof. en dév.
régional, Université Laval
- S'il y a une chose que
la littérature nous apprend,
c'est que quand on ajoute
des voies autoroutières, on crée
de la congestion. On ne règle
pas le problème de congestion.
Ce qu'on va faire, c'est étaler
la ville encore plus et rendre
une dépendance à l'automobile
qui est encore plus forte. Et
là, on va se dire: ah! bien ça y
est, ça donne rien d'investir
dans le transport en commun,
la ville est trop étalée!
- Le gouvernement vient
quand même d'officialiser
la construction du futur tramway
et financera aussi une centaine
de kilomètres de voies réservées
aux autobus dans la région.
Le troisième lien, quant à lui,
est prévu ouvrir au plus tôt
en 2032.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio